you looked very good I wanted to say in
the green room and you you're taking
care of yourself I take care of myself I
groom myself as opposed to someone else
doing it for you all right
no actually I do you know I didn't get a
manicure the other day I go like once a
year I get a manicure you ever get a
manicure
you know what I don't get a manicure
I've always too self-conscious I've
never had one but people saw white I
know just about yeah it's this it's
sexist but a guy sitting there getting a
manicure it always feels a little like I
don't know I don't know if I could do
that
[Applause]
so yeah I get one of those and in fact
the other day I was going to get when
you got a minute yeah
got a minute
yes you know how you're not supposed to
look at the full eclipse of the Sun yeah
they say not to look at it with your
eyes but I somebody sometimes I always
do what there's people that do it you
quick paid that you have to like that
yeah and yet nothing happened to me yeah
so I go into the to the salon a nail
salon they call it and I'm sitting in a
chair and then they bring this this
woman and like a 26 year old beautiful
blonde blue eyes and sit her right
across from me like this
she's in the chair right up right over
me and she's breastfeeding her baby and
I don't want to look at it like the Sun
you know I don't want to look at her and
doing everything not to look at her I'm
like you know yeah I was like Ray
Charles playing the bass and she's right
there like six feet away you know it's a
small place and and I caught her eyes
like for one second it felt like five
minutes but we both connect the eyes and
I felt so awkward even the baby let go
of the breast he goes really are you
serious yeah
one has to last longer it wasn't like
you know the full Eclipse was partial
coverage of the breasts so I didn't see
anything I have my glasses on - so it
didn't matter right but but but yeah
it's good to kind of go in there and get
groomed a little yeah I'm gonna try that
especially if you know are you not
you'll never try I know I know this guy
who's never he'll never get close to it
yeah yeah - awkward you know you've been
you fly constantly all around the
country and I that's a good observation
and you and you just kidding don't ever
do that was enough I love his invasive
yeah I didn't like that did you see that
that was very invasive I didn't like
that Conan I love this crowd so much I
have a I have a connection with this
crowd I'm only out here for a couple I
I feel like a synergy I guess and I
think I'm falling in love with them and
that scares me because you know somebody
else would come in tomorrow and they'll
see them and then you know they'll
forget about me but so we'll just be
friends but yeah yeah this is a
short-lived yeah yeah but I love hands
like when somebody's eating oh yeah yeah
what the hand they're eating with I
always look at the other hand cuz it's
just poised right there it's poised
ready for any kind of command from their
head they don't really need it right now
yeah it's waiting yeah and it's waiting
it's waiting I kind of that's my
observation of hands Wow next time
you're eating with somebody look at the
other hand that's not doing the feeding
yeah guess what I don't think I will you
don't go to the nail salon no and you
don't do that yeah I'm not gonna do that
we'll figure out something you could do
you